electrolyte it up okay when we got
warzone rated 143 out of 150 average
rating 1756 time handicap times will be
adjusted according to players as rating
in order to balance things out criteria
none here we go Matthew joy give me this
thing over here double the points
efore it is best by test uh-oh whoo
I wanted the French my opponent gave me
a my opponent juked me right there gave
me the quick Juke right there
let's support this kick around the night
if there is a capture I'm starting with
very little time the go here so I could
get Bishop to f4 is my mouse acting up
on me you better not be mount better not
be messing up acting up queen d3 because
there might be Queen d7 my knight wants
to get to c4 he's gonna fall in love
with the C 4 square 92 to c4 pinpoint
this pond there might be tension between
the rooks exchange rooks I could grab
the a pond half open file Bishop back I
grab the roof there be after retreat
retreat Queen Knight has to recapture in
the meantime okay we're not having that
I got the pond and now be pond soon I
have a flight square for my king he's
not afraid my opponents down time eyes
and pond wise rook a one I played here
okay
let's no no no no no no right here's
okay pond push pins pin pin pin pin pin
b6 coming up this this could be a nice
home for my rook can weasel around down
and over less than 10 what do we got a
time time ticker is anything anything
back to tournament to a bunch of two's
okay William oh we played once before
this was a it was a really tight game
from what I recall it was a five-minute
one
okay uh-oh bishop trap I money for here
we go I'm launching it it's getting
ready to be launched
launching pad get ready fishing let's
kill let's kill this guy right here oh
wait a second oh boy
uh-oh everything's falling look up and
over this mate
King moves and then its mate tkl back to
tournament six three and a bunch of
two's okay let's go to four - all righty
AJ Hansen AJ Hansen oh four okay ah
let's go this way this way instead I'm
not gonna get deep for an I might as
well do that and now let's go with this
let's go night you know you want to play
on the kingside f5 coming up I have five
I might want to consider Bishop eats
free no no I don't want to consider that
I'll drop my b2 pond let's lock it up f5
coming in f6 is juicy square it's a
juicy square I'm telling you c5 is also
hit d6 I'm on the light square bishop
I'm gonna come now I'm gonna take that
get rid of that light square bishop let
mine now see the world he wants to see
the world and he's seeing a lot of the
world and now back to f6 it is or d6 two
good points here let's go to f6 and then
get my Queen to h6 and then defend here
first this is a problem isn't it is it a
problem get this night out of here
before it's a problem so I'm gonna try
and mask this idea soon okay and then
let's go here right now oh are they
gonna give me their dark square bishop
even oh it's kind of dead isn't it
I got to get to the h-file that's gonna
be the plan
how much time we're about even what's
time break it open break it up here
bishop sacks coming up oh the f-pawn has
to capture otherwise it oh this is this
is double check and then mate right
the King has to take like a resignation
back to tournament 12 9 sixes all right
who's this
TBS be Br all right Sicilian a lot of
Sicilian looking for the sharp play here
in the the one-minute ones usually
sometimes I'll play solid or solid or
chock it up that's another one solid I'm
looking for the solid or positions
oh you're it is H - H - there it is I
did watch that video if Kelvin is here
in the twitch chat half baby laughs man
that video H - we see it again oh no I'm
playing against myself here I'm playing
against myself here uh-oh I might have
to sack a minor piece here we go push
the pawn I just let it be taken here we
go the bishop sack line of7
be prepared kick a queen around it's
very scary I'm gonna do this though I
think there's something to it I got the
bishop that was the thing that was to it
the king could have taken though okay
let's do this
and now the brook is should be shaking
in his boots he should be a boot shaker
on the rook
get ready be scared be very scared
what's going on just take the Queen and
the rook okay oh it's tough playing
against this chest network guy
oh man
okay the canyons running for the hills
oh there goes a night okay
check hit the bishop give another check
II kick the King around check no no no
no I'm there 15 seconds
check this has got to be made soon no
why did I do that huh oh look
oops tooken oh there's another one they
could have took in the rookie wonderful
a grammar lesson and everything yes
everybody loves a good grammar lesson
come on let's go here we go here we go
here we go
it was tooken that stood seven Czech
Queen checkmate
close to it there's me back to turret
that took forever twenty twenty twenty
seventeen sixteen okay or no I have
thirty I lied I have thirty this guy
again the big bad bear okay alright I
have um I'm gonna launch the H pond I
don't know about this set up here
looking okay okay okay okay
my knight oh man I want my knight right
there let's build a center first right
here and right here clean and then get
my knight uh-huh this pocket be taken
seven times already wow this is not a
good thing to be doing you gotta hang on
to those pawns they're precious
the pawns are precious okay so I want a
piece right here let's do this
no no no no I gotta watch out for a
night right here let me do this no let's
not do that okay well okay the night
playing here would have been pretty good
let's go over here twenty seven let's go
let's go dark square bishop you're
stupid you're not doing anything let's
go let's go let's go look over here no
no no no why is it that night it's such
a pest get out of there
no I can't do this twenty-one here we go
get to the Saturday night
there you go I should have done that a
lot sooner okay let's go here take my
night just take them take them no no no
no right here
recapture my clean pile up on this pond
I need a primo primo get out of there
tonight get out and now my LightSquared
Bishop needs to do something more
exciting more exciting right here he's
more excited about things okay that rook
can't be too happy 12 Oh that nights
gonna kill me
come here Bishop to the rescue okay
double up what am i doing make progress
I'm not making progress over here bishop
this is where you wanted to be all day
all day you wanted to be there and you
didn't go there now we want to get this
in there we go it's coming together how
much time is left
push through break it open
hit the Queen look for me any move just
move back to terminal
forty two thirty three thirty they're
down on time close that tab here we go
twenty second yeah 20 seconds left 20
minutes left right on the nose are they
gonna pair me up yes they are okay
double those points because we want to
we want to win
Oh quick resigner come on you drop that
you know you dropped a piece just there
here it is here we go can you believe it
it's happening again not the first time
what's it gonna be things are
I got the Queen got the Queen that's me
the King needed to run he didn't run 56
56 49 both of us have seven games in
we're seven four seven rail okay
c5 get ready get ready for what okay
we're not we're not having them we're
not gonna be going fish on this one are
we let's go D 5 D 5 D 5 D 5 D 5 it is
takes no we're not having that come on
just take you know you want to take here
we go
no soup for you Bishop block off the
bishop right there and now Knight right
here coming up the bishop is shut out of
the game I'm on the bishop this is TKO
take the knight take the bait oh they
saw a ghost
I think they saw a ghost right there
yeah they saw a ghost my queen is scared
my queen is seeing ghosts right now I
should just play there I didn't know
okay let's go here I could give pieces
back the bishops dead I'm up I'm up a
piece yet and out of that oh this is a
deadly check oh oh this is big trouble
anything just move anything off a piece
this bit I'm also like two pieces right
because of this guy this is a problem
once again the light square bishop you
just take that guy out and I gotta run
home here my knight needs to go
somewhere else he's running out of
squares there on the rook rook was on
the bishop check anything come on just
move just make sure you move fast here
at the rookie I need to get rid of this
rook he needs to go and then I'm gonna
oh boy the bishop is cooked now I'm
going after him
there's no way out he's a prisoner he's
a prisoner of his own pawns how much
time no time back to tournament 9000
ninety nine for nine what okay D crusher
let's go a four oh I should have played
okay it's all right
I was gonna say I have a fantasy
variation I didn't I wasn't expecting
that here we go well my dark square
bishop better get doing something much
quicker in this game much quicker right
now do something get rid of the dark
square bishop and then get my Knight to
g5 my other night where over here it's
probably a good idea and then get in
what break things open here I'm gonna
lock it up my poem isn't careful it's
locked over a year and now play is gonna
happen in this side of the board my
knight whoa no no no no no no no no no
let's go Queen to g3 and now there's
possibilities for what okay I have
everything defended I do my knight wants
to go somewhere else right here's a good
spot I'm on this pond now it's a problem
also I'm on this okay
I could take the knight now with check
okay and then this and then what sixteen
seconds though my opponents been playing
very fast are they gonna still play yeah
they're still gonna play and they should
my king better run for the hills here
where is he running to where is my king
think he's running to right here okay
now that it's locked up let's go over
here grab this pawn come back and my
knight wants to play also he wants to be
right here and then I want to push upon
push again and then push again and then
me back to tournament
what haha I want to read that number
it's too high I can't read that number
130 how do you get out of 30 points come
on quick quick resigning you saw me
supposed to do that to me and it's a sad
day what somebody has honored 30 and I'm
sitting that 90 come on
Castle kingside so I could launch the
Jeep on let's go ooh oh you I'm gonna
work myself into a pen it's a little all
right now I have this sneaky sneaky
tricks let's get out of that get out of
their night got the night and then this
so my Bishop is protecting my night g5
okay light squares I should just taken
it that was stupid oh good me I needed
that back to tournament 130 110 he's got
one game up on me 14 minutes but he's
probably ready to win again before I
have to keep winning if I have any
chance if I have any chance I need to
keep winning let's go f4 my name is
gonna be chopped up and okay I have an F
file for for free kind of let's go no I
don't want to open up the F file for you
let's go like this my queen wants to
play on the other side of the board
that's a good move crap okay now let's
come over here
f7 f7 f7 f 7 pin the night kill the
night kill the night pin the night
tactics let's block I wanna do what what
do I wanna do double up kill the night
oh no no no no no no no oh the night
could have played there that would have
been scary how much time is left
ok let's do this Forks
mmm over here I guess there's gonna be
Queen trade and stuff I'm gonna have to
go click come on now what right here
okay I'm winning upon winning another
pawn rook and pawn endgame 10 seconds to
fight back from my rook is very active
getting another one oh come on this
which should be resignation right
resigned yes back to tournament 150 130
it's got an extra game in 151 30 and
then Queen sak 103 am I gonna get paired
up if we get paired up that's gonna be a
big one that's gonna be the super
heavyweight battle right there right
what do you call that the I'm fishing
for words and the words aren't here
speaking of fish speaking of fish here
we go Queen right here you know you want
to play Queen right here it's very
tempting do it okay it's still on be
very scared be very scared
Oh be very scared scary time my queen is
gonna weasel around 2 h2 take the knight
oh the night's gonna play here crap are
they listening to the stream you
shouldn't be stopping Queen here I'm
gonna let the knight go here if he
really wants to so there could be a
killer check or not so killer my king is
gonna run away oh this is mate yes back
to tournament 170 150 I think I need to
get paired up against the top guy in
order to take him out let's see if that
is the case Oh quick resigner what do
you know 160 170 170 is first ok d
crusher again let's go let's go C 5 I
was propelled 10 points up a quick 10 no
come on with your mouse lips what's
wrong with you ah f 6 oh yeah it's right
away you're clean - and your seat pond
let's get this in before it's too late
yes chop at night chop that night right
up is there a piece that's just gonna be
thrown right there it might happen let's
get rid of the light square bishop he
needs to go I don't have any time my
time go why am I even pre moving that
there there's no real cake rook takes
rook that's stupid
f3 I have no time no time to do anything
exciting my queen is pretty much trapped
run away oh man this is scary this is
scary
very very very scary hit the rope hit
the rug 21 seconds where's my time
where'd it go okay double up double up
kill the night kill the night kill a
night my dark square Bishop is a stupid
stupid piece look at him
Wow well done well done bishop ah you
are a fool get him here okay here we go
Knight my knight wants to be where right
here look at this stupid bishop wow wow
stupid Bishop let's go do something this
is your way to two activity you want to
be active check and now she's I know the
Queen's gonna come over and kill me
let's defend this is sad I only have
eight seconds no no no I got a pre move
time to pre move time time to bring a
pre move pre-move throw in a check
they'll never suspect that one another
check checks for everybody more checks
clock burners move move move
here we go
come on I'm not gonna win this
objectively
I got a pre move like a maniac they'll
never suspect that one or this one they
suspected that one how much time how
much time come on just burn
yes that's it Oh 210 he's got 210 108
oh yeah 210 180 oh man that takes a lot
I do eight minutes and change here we go
Aldo 70 is having a good tournament here
Sicilian more Sicilian everybody loves
the Sicilian it's all about the Sicilian
King side castle my Knights gonna get
kicked away if I push the pawn I'm crazy
and if I don't push the pawn
I don't push the pawn same thing okay
here we go 92 93 f5 and everybody's
happy
especially my dark square bishop let's
go let's go f6 for the win take with the
Queen I'm not sure she's gonna get beat
up soon the Knights gonna hit her okay
let's go this square right here I really
want to get there I really really really
want to get there okay let's do this I
got it five now five is mine get out of
this oh let's just take him out he's too
much he's bad news
open it up over here keep it closed my
king needs to run run King run over here
where it's safe
let me take this out give a check oh man
this pawn push is gonna come okay good
good to be good good good trade cleans
even though I've doubled pawns it's
gonna be all right
is it gonna be all right take that guy
there now we have a past part if that's
taken it says take them yes
hit the rook get my each pawn rolling
get this H pawn going go go go go go
let me just make sure that Queen isn't
going to do anything
that's gonna bother me let's take this
and then get my rook up what's going on
here it's another pun queen trade how
much time enough time right Queens are
off give you check let's go if the rook
moves then um okay let's get out that oh
this is bad okay let me go here
my Queens gonna have to come back they
don't have any time back to chairman 250
oh come on
250 I even had a quick resigner - they
must add a quick resigner three or four
okay come on can we get this could it
happen again
Castle come on yes
h2 it is again back to tournament land
250 to 2000 Gandy crusher
efore and what are we gonna have Oh
ticker time ticker okay here we go
Center Oh they're giving me everything
is that what's happening
get up seven catch them in a pre move
nope that happened whoa let's get out of
that my opponent was ready to catch me
in a pre move can I get the Queen stop
that palm push and push here Knight
right here I'm gonna try it
check pins I'm gonna I'm gonna allow
that oh okay let's go here I'm gonna go
with my queen actually no no no
now what am i doing
ah what am i doing me I want me where's
me I'm floundering I'm floundering what
am i doing oh I had an attack when what
happened to it
ah stupid moves that's what happened
stupid moves happened oh I got the Queen
designation time push the pond get rid
of the light square bishop yes back to
chairmat they resigned 272 40 30 minutes
is Earth yeah 30 minutes 30 points is
hard to overcome right there what can
one do c5e six quick resign errs that's
where it's at I need the resigns
where are the resigns H puns H pangs H
puns
even if I'm losing a pun okay dark
squares get here and that's gonna be
your favorite square right there all
that pine is picked off okay let's
strike in the center maybe my bishop
could see that pond one day it is it's
gonna see it block queenside castle rook
e8 Bishop d6 here we go rook e8 capture
and I got the queen or a bishop bishop
block and I got this Bishop III
otherwise it's TKO resignation come on
this is down a piece chop pins forks
more pins I'm on the night castle of
Queen here
I got the Queen come on you know this is
time to resign right come on a clock
ticker o clock ticker let's go here
mates looking for those mates
okay where the mates there's no time for
my opponent everything's following the
house the house is falling that's me
okay I'm glad I didn't prima back-back
determine 292 62 29 I need two more wins
and one of them probably I need to be
paired up against him and I'd have to
win that one there's only time for one
more
I could only be assured of one more game
here and it's probably not gonna be
enough it's not happening
nope no let's hang on to that it might
be challenged again and yeah okay so now
Castle f5 is probably a good idea soon
and I should have done it well sooner
well let's let's try this I'm gonna get
that let's try this
I gotta go quicker much quicker here
okay Bishop out to where oh I shouldn't
have done that
okay well the night's gonna be dropping
a bomb on the position right here bishop
check how about my knight has a good
square am I getting the back rank mated
knight on e4
okay forks everywhere I need a flight
square for my king how should I make one
I think on g2 but my queen needs to do
something else she needs to come over
here there was a check though let's go
here it's a little scary I'm gonna do it
it's a little scary but I'm gonna do it
and knows everything no no no my he has
to run he has to run very very fast run
King Queen g1 I'm okay with this I'm
okay with this I think um at this pond
what am i doing get my king in the
center okay he's in the center now he's
happy let's stop this first submit those
pawns on dark squares and this pond
right here I should have played here
I'll do it next okay now I have targets
oh that's really weird the bishops gonna
play there but or is it I better take a
man
oh man oh I'm scared I'm very very
scared right now oh oh okay wait
there's no time determine sell for
second place it's man clothes 308 how do
you catch somebody who racks up 308
points good games